so let's say that you have hypertension
and you'd like to figure out what to do
about it
there actually is a lot of good news
here so
there are about four different major
things i can think of that you can do to
help reduce hypertension fairly easy
things you can do in your own home
the first is your diet
so
there's something called the dietary
approaches
dietary approaches
to stopping hypertension
which basically means that you can
actually use your diet to help reduce
your blood pressure
and a few different groups have actually
come together and endorse this
set of guidelines like the american
heart association
and the mayo clinic
and
i actually went through and tried to
figure out exactly what this dash diet
would recommend for me
so i'm going to draw for you
a plate this is kind of a plate of food
if you can imagine all my meals in one
day on one plate of food this is what
the dash diet would recommend this is
one day
and i take about 2 000 calories in a day
so the dash diet suggests that for me i
should have about five fruits in a day
and i should have five vegetables in a
day
so a total of 10 fruits and vegetables
and then on top of that about seven
grains
of which three are whole grains
so three whole grains
and for the remainder of my plate it
suggests two
dairy products
so that would be something like non-fat
milk or low-fat milk products like
yogurt cheese
and two meat products so
it's not required that you eat meat
in fact it's not necessary at all but if
you do the recommendation is to have no
more than two
meat servings in a day
and if you are gonna have meat
definitely like a lean meat
so these are the servings in one day
that it recommends and on top of that in
a week it says i i should probably have
about four servings of nuts and seeds
and it also went on to say that i should
probably try to limit how many sweets
i take in and this would be like candy
or any sort of dessert donuts
and any sort of fatty food or oil
so fats and oils
and this would be like potato chips or
fries things like that to really try to
limit those things and if you do this
for a couple weeks you're actually shown
in studies to have lower
blood pressure at the end of it so
within two weeks this starts you know to
make a difference which is pretty
phenomenal
so you can tell based on the way i've
drawn this out that the dash die is
really stressing fruits
i'm writing as an f and v for vegetables
and also stressing lots of grains g
so lots of fruits veg vegetables and
grains it's also
mentioned in the dash diet that you
should be on a low sodium diet so low
sodium
which is
a limit of 1500 milligrams of sodium in
a day
okay
and finally the dash diet
says that if you drink alcohol let's say
you drink alcohol
that you should really try to limit your
alcohol to less than
two servings of alcohol in a day so less
than or equal to two servings of alcohol
in a day
now in addition to diet there are a few
other things you can do as well so you
could exercise and exercise is actually
very important in trying to reduce your
blood pressure
and there are a few different types of
exercise you know there's resistance
training with weights there's stretching
as folks that do yoga can tell you
but this the type of exercise that's
probably most helpful for hypertension
is aerobic exercise so you want to try
to stress aerobic exercise
now when i say aerobic exercise i mean
things like going for a swim
or
you're going for a jog
and maybe even a brisk walk if
if that suits what you enjoy
or a bike ride so something like this
that really gets your heart pumping and
flowing blood all or getting blood to
flow all the way throughout your body
instead of just one muscle group
so aerobic exercise is really important
and in terms of how much aerobic
exercise a rough rule of thumb that i
use is
suggesting about 30 minutes
per day
for about five days a week
and i find that that's a very reasonable
thing that a lot of people can do
and
and find enjoyable
okay so diet and exercise if you're
doing these two things you're likely to
be losing weight
and i'm going to talk about weight in
terms of a bmi a body mass index
so if you're
if you're hypertensive it's really good
idea to try to get your bmi in a healthy
range
and for adults that would be between
18.5 and 25. it's a very healthy
range of bmi
and it's actually really important that
you get there especially if you're
on the high side so let's say you're
obese and your bmi is over 30 or you're
slightly overweight over 25
getting that bmi down below 25 is really
really critical
and finally for smokers
it's really important to try to quit
smoking
so this is a fantastic time to kind of
take your health into your hands
and finally quit smoking or using
tobacco products
and
nowadays we actually have so many
medications
that really help with this as well as
counseling that it makes it much much
easier to to try to quit smoking it's
never an easy thing to do but it's
certainly a lot easier when you have
medications and counseling to help you
and you have a good reason to do it like
you have hypertension so these are these
are the four kind of things to keep in
mind in terms of things you can do at
home